hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled high throughput assay
for monitoring covid19 antibodies and
their isotypes
this webinar is part of an ongoing
coronavirus
virtual webinar series i'm susie valdez
of labrutz and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab route
and sponsored by luminex for more
information about luminex go to
luminexcorp.com now let's get started
before we begin i want to remind
everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate and submit as many questions
as you'd like
him during their presentation to do so
simply type
into the ask a question box and
click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational
and offers continuing education credit
click
on the continuing education credits tab
located in the top
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process
to obtain those credits i now present
today's speaker dr susan zola pasner
professor of medicine at the division of
infectious diseases
at icon school of medicine at mount
sinai
in new york city welcome dr ziller
presner
thank you susie um
today i'd like to share with you the
work that we've done
over the past two and a half months
to develop a high
throughput assay for antibodies
specific for sars covid
ii in covin 19
patients and show you some of the
results that we have achieved using
this asset so just as an
introduction though you may not need it
i just want to share with you this
cartoon
of the structure of the virus we're
going to be
focusing today on the spike protein
shown in yellow that covers the surface
of
the virus particle sometimes
antibody assays are directed
toward the nucleocapsid which is shown
in pink
but the work that we are doing today
is focusing on detecting antibodies to
the spike protein
and a portion of the spike protein which
i will show you
now so rather than a cartoon
this is a molecular
diagram or molecular structure
of the spike protein as a whole
with the receptor binding domain
highlighted
in red in this
in this slide what you can see
is that the spike protein is anchored
in the membrane of the virus
envelope which is um at the bottom of
the slide or would be at the bottom of
the slide
and then the upper part of the structure
where the receptor binding domain
resides
is the distal portion of the
s protein now in terms of a description
of the antigens that we use in the acid
we use the spike protein as i said and
the receptor binding domain which is
abbreviated as rbd let's go over the
details of the spike protein it is
referred to
it comes from the s protein it is
constituted of the s protein and the
spike itself
is a trimer a homotrimer
of three copies of this s protein
each which is 100 approximately 140 kb
the spike protein binds to the host cell
via the surface angiotensin converting
enzyme to ace
so the spike protein binds to the ace2
on the surface of receptor receptive
cells
for coating the beads that we use in the
assay
we use the s protein ectodomain
which is composing 1213 amino
acids and at the c-terminus
of the s-protein a thrombosin cleavage
site has been added along
with a t4 on trimerization domain
and a hexahistidine tag
this was expressed designed and
expressed
by florian kramer at mount sinai
school of medicine now a portion of the
spike protein
that i showed you before in red in the
previous slide is the receptor binding
domain
this is an area of the s
protein and that consists of amino acids
319 to 541
out of this protein that i mentioned to
you has 1213 amino acids so this is
in the middle this is a region in the
middle of the protein
and this antigen as we're using it
consists of the natural n-terminal
signal peptide of the s-protein
fused to the rbd sequence and then join
with the c-terminal hexahistidine tagged
at this
um at the c-terminus the histidine tags
are
used for purification of of the proteins
as they're expressed
now just a quick summary introduction
and summary to the luminex
assay the principle of the assay
is that there are different bead sets
here labeled a 4
a 5 6 and 7. and each bead
has an individual fluorochrome
tags that
identifies each of the different bead
sets
in the assay i'm going to be talking
about today we're only using two bead
sets
one that binds to the s protein to the
spike
and the second bead set that binds to
the rbd protein
we mix these antigen coated beads
with the serum that contains
the antibodies that we're looking for or
in the case of
controls of course there is no antibody
there
that's what we're trying to distinguish
so we have the beads
you see down at the bottom that the
antigens are either the
s protein or the rbd and then
we add the serum or plasma
um if there are antibodies in the serum
or plasma
it coats the bead it binds to the coated
bead
that's shown in the upper right here
so you have the antibodies bound to the
antigen bound to the bead
and then we use a biotinylated
detection antibody which we call a
secondary antibody in this case
it would be one of a number of different
types of
anti-immunoglobulins so a secondary
antibody that binds
all immunoglobulins or one for instance
that only binds to igm or only binds to
iga
etcetera and we'll go through that in a
minute and then
for the readout a final reagent is added
which is streptavidin labeled with
phycoerythrin
it will bind to the secondary antibodies
and the biotinylated secondary
antibodies
so as i mentioned the detection is with
secondary antibodies to total igg
total total ig to igg
subclasses iga subclasses or to igm
these beads once they are coated
mixed with the plasma specimen um
mixed with the secondary antibody and
mixed with the streptavidin
by coarserin are then added into
96 well plates both
bead sets are in
each well and then the contents of the
wells are
red in a luminex analyzer
and we can determine if there are
antibodies
that are binding to rbd and or
the s protein we can quantitate that
with titration curve and i will show you
that in a minute
um this is the um
outline of the assay we can coat
the antigen onto the beads and then
store the beads
for at least a month at minus 80 degrees
centigrade
and then use them as we need them um
we add the washed coupled beads and the
serum to
wells in the 9612 plates we wait
30 minutes and then we add the
biotinylated secondary
antibody the anti-ig we wait another 30
minutes of course they're washing steps
between each of these
and then we add the streptavidin
phycorythrin
um wait another 30 minutes wash
and then read in the lumina luminex
instrument so
the assay that i'm going to show you is
both
a qualitative a binary essay and a
quantitative
assay and i'm going to show you some of
the data that we have generated now
so this is a dot plot of the screening
of
plasma from covid positive and
negative subjects on the
left we're showing the results with um
the
beads that are coated with the spike
protein and
just stands for the fact that it was
expressed in mammalian cells
and on the right you see the results
using
the rbd also expressed in mammalian
cells
these data were generated with the
plasma that
with plasma that were diluted of one to
two hundred
and as you can see here in red
in both graphs
the coven 19 positive patients
score strongly and
the coping negative patients have only
background reactivity
this is an experiment that was done
using plasma
from volunteers
and the next slide i'm showing you the
data with sarah
so you can use both serum and plasma
and they give equivalent results um
what i'm showing you on in this slide
again on the left
is the reactivity of the sera to m spike
and on the right
is reactivity to rbd
um again the sera are being tested in a
dilution
of one to two hundred um on
the right of each side are three
negatives
copy negative controls
and and then the colored bars represent
the open positive subjects
now there's some uh the first thing that
you need to notice
here is that it's obvious that amongst
the covent positive
specimens there are tremendous
differences in the levels of antibodies
and this we see commonly
the levels vary
enormously what has been reported in the
literature is that
patients with severe disease have a
higher level
of antibodies than patients or subjects
who've had much milder disease and i can
show you that
in just just using these few samples
amongst
many others that we've done um
the three bars that are outlined in
black here
shown the bars are in red show
the serif from a single patient taken at
day 8 11 and 15
after the beginning of symptoms and
as we know after an infection on one of
the things that you can
use to diagnose an infection is an
increasing tighter of antibodies in the
serum and that's exactly what you see
and you can see that in a very short
time
in a period of one week from eight days
to 15 days
as is shown over these three bars
the level of antibody is going up
dramatically both despite and to rbd
in this slide the orange bars are
highlighted
and these are longitudinal specimens
from
taken from a different patient and
these two specimens were taken at days
7 and 11 and again you can see the
rising tides
the other bars
[Music]
represent a variety of patients or a
variety of
specimens from individuals who
had tested positive in the clinical lab
so their pcrs were positive
and their antibody levels are
all positive well above the cutoff for
negatives which
are so low that you can't see them it's
not that they weren't done
they were done but they they uh the
levels were so low that you
you don't see the bars and the negatives
so
all of the positives are positive uh
for the presence of antibodies we ran
um these six again spike and then two of
these
six were run against um the rbd
show similar results now
these are what we call the results from
screening
we screen the sarah at one to two
hundred
and those um specimens that are positive
it wants 200
um we go well actually those specimens
that are positive for rbd
um are titrated and
what i want to show you in this slide
out have the titration results with the
same specimens that i showed you
in the screen in the previous slides
so you can see these beautiful titration
curves
that we get when we're titrating
um from one to fifty out to
a dilution of uh just over six
thousand here um and um you can see that
it's 1 to 6 400. um we're
down close to baseline with most of the
uh
specimens but some of them
uh still have quite high titer and will
probably go out
to 12 000 or even 24 000
in in this particular essay
um when um we do have in
negatives in this
graph shown as n1
2 and 3 in black they
lie right on the y-axis
at zero but to give you a better sense
of the negatives i'm showing you
in this slide what the negatives look
like in terms of the titration
the green lines lie right at the
very close to the zero mark whereas a
positive pool of
sarah at 1-100 dilution
spores up here where the red dots are
and again
the negative pool and the
pbs between um negative controls
are in black and again it's very hard to
see them because they're right down
at baseline we also
ran a series of specimens um
that were drawn from
volunteers in an irb approved study
um they're pre-pandemics here that were
drawn
before november um over
i think 2017 to 2019.
on the right we're showing um
two positive sarah
and the red bars um the next two
tiny bars were negative sarah
over on the right hand side
are specimens
that come from the positive pool that i
showed you before
this very high blue bar
the negative pool and the pbs
and the pre-pandemic specimens you can
see
range all the way in the middle here
they are just barely detectable
with the exception of this last specimen
which was actually negative
in the rbd screen but did
come up slightly positive in in
the spike so
now what i'd like to highlight is the
relative properties
of the elisa assay analyze it assay
versus the luminex platform
so in this slide
we titrated the same
serum um and this is from
um that first patient where we had
the longitudinal specimens at day
8 11 and 15. they're color-coded here so
um this is the specimen from day eight
and um in sort of salmon color
in red is the specimen from day
11 and in maroon is a specimen from day
15. and in the upper graph
we're looking at the results generated
with
luminex and in the
lower graph you see the results
generated by
elisa and what you can see
by looking at the 50 percent um
half maximal binding value which is
identified by the the dashed lines
is that the um the half max
value or tighter that we
identify for instance in the 15 day
sample by luminex is one to 2500
whereas the same specimen in elisa
is um has
a half maximal value of less than one to
five hundred
so there is at least of uh five-fold
and in some cases a tenth up to a
tenfold difference
with the luminex assay of being much
more sensitive
in addition to the greater sensitivity
of the luminex assay
um we have been
able to reduce the amount of the anagen
needed per test so with the elisa
the wells are typically coated
with .05 milliliters or 50 microliters
of the antigen solution of two
micrograms
of antigen per ml and
using um that in 96 well
plates means that you're using 0.1
micrograms of antigen per test in
contrast to that
when we can we can coat the luminex
beads
with 12 micrograms of anagen
per 3 million beads which gives us 1200
tests
and that means that we can use 0.005
micrograms of antigen per test
so a 20 fold decrease in the amount of
antigen that you use
which obviously results in
cost savings so
another advantage of luminex over the
elastic assay
is indicated here in the luminex
assay we can couple the beads
in advance and store them frozen until
we need them
once we need them we take them out of
the freezer
we incubate them with serum or plasma
for 30 minutes we add this
biotinylated secondary antibody for 30
minutes and then we add the streptavidin
like orythrin for 30 minutes and then we
read
you'd have to add a few minutes here for
each of the washes
but generally this test takes only an
hour and a half to do
and you do the rbd
analysis and the spike protein
analysis simultaneously so within
an hour and a half or two hours you have
the information on 28 specimens
in the plate in just under two hours
in contrast in the elisa plates you have
to coat the plates overnight
then you have to block for an hour and
you have to add serum
for two hours then you add a
horseradish peroxidase secondary
antibody
then for another hour and then the
substrate
before you can stop and read the plates
so the eliza requires an overnight
preparation of the plate and then
for our assay to do 14 specimens
moreover you have to do the rbd
on one day determine which ones of those
are positive and then do the spike
on the following day and so
that means that the turnaround time is
two days for the elisa test
whereas the turnaround time for the
luminex is just
over two hours so two hours versus two
days
we can summarize the advantages of the
luminex
over the elisa as we as is shown here
which i've already mentioned it provides
both a qualitative
binary assessment and a quantitative
platform for the assessment of cover 19
antibodies
it uses 20-fold less antigen for tests
than the elisa
it is at least two and a half fold
faster to run
actually even faster than that um it can
run in a half a day or two hours
um half a day if you include the time it
takes to dilute the samples but if you
have
a robotic system that that is done for
you
um but it can run in less than one day
um in addition we have determined
although i'm not showing you
the data that you can run the essays on
one day
and read them on the next day if that is
more convenient
in the context of the lab
that's doing the acid we can perform the
rbd screen and the spike titration
simultaneously with luminex but
with eliza it's a sequential assay for
the rbd
and then the spike as i mentioned before
the turnaround time is much faster
and the level of sensitivity is five to
ten fold
better in the luminex than it is in
eliza
um both serum and plasma can be used
and that's true for the luminex as well
as the elisa
now um that is a description
of the the antibody
test for um presence and
level of uh total antibodies
in serum and plasma but we were
particularly interested in looking at
what types of antibodies
are produced in response to
infection with stars covered two
and so i'm going to show you a series of
experiments now looking at the different
types
isotypes of antibodies that are in the
serum and plasma
of patients so here
is the method it is basically the same
method that we used before
um
but uh we use um
antibodies to the various subclasses
of or isotypes of antibodies and i'll
show you that in a minute
how did we pick the antibodies that we
were going to
use as secondary antibodies um
a lot of secondary antibodies or
anti immunoglobulins are sold
by companies that
are labeled as being specific for igg-1
iga igm etc but in fact when you test
them they are not necessarily as
specific as
they are labeled by some of the
companies so
we wanted to be sure that what we were
measuring when we said
we're measuring iga is truly iga
and that the secondary antibodies are
specific for iga and not cross-reactive
with other isotypes and so we did
a control experiment that i'm going to
show you and for this control experiment
the beads were coated with myeloma
proteins
of known immunoglobulin isotypes so here
for this control only for these control
experiments we
coated beads with myeloma proteins of
igg-1
or iga or igm etc and then these beads
were incubated with the various
secondary biotinylated antibodies that
we bought from various companies
that were labeled as being specific for
total ig
or for the ig g
subclass or the iga subclass the igm
and then we developed them as we
normally did with the streptavidin
and in this line you can see just some
of the reagents that we tested
and that we decided to go forward with
i'm not going to show you
the secondary antibodies that didn't
work because we don't use them
there is an antibody that we use
that measures total ig
total immunoglobulin and that
secondary antibody reacts with beads
coated with igg-1
myeloma proteins or igg 2a
igg3 igg4 iga1
iga2 and igm that's in the upper
left-hand corner
on the upper right hand corner you see
the isotypes that are picked up by a
reagent a secondary reagent
that is specific for igg
so just a minute ago i showed you a
reagent that picks up
totally immunoglobulin which is ga m
but on the upper right you see the
controls
with the secondary animation antibody
that picks up
igg-1 igg2 igg3
and igg4 but not iga1
a2 or m another
excellent reagent was specific for iga1
subclass this is on the lower left
and you see that it only reacts with
iga1
myeloma protein and none of the other
myeloma proteins
and similarly for the antibody
to the igm subclass
in the lower right you see that this
antibody
reacts with the igm
coated beads there is a little bit of
cross reactivity with igg3
and ig4 but it's much less and we
decided we could live with that for the
igm specific
antibody so using reagents that were
designed
and selected for their specificity
in the luminex assay we went on to
analyze the isotypes in serum plasma
of the sarcoma to
infected patients and uninfected donors
so in this slide what i'm showing you
is the level of total immunoglobulin
against the m spike um
yeah and this is in um seri
and plasma so
this is looking at total ig which means
igg
iga and igm this
is looking at antibodies specific for
the spike
on the right hand side you can see
that the
there's very very little reactivity
just background activity defined by
the negative specimens that we tested
many of which came from from the blood
bank
um and the dotted line that is hard to
see because it is so close to
the baseline is the cutoff
which is based on the mean plus three
standard deviations
of the negative specimens that we run in
each experiment
and what you can see here is that
total igg is found in
all of the positive specimens
as i pointed out before the levels
vary tremendously the readout as with
all of these experiments was
with mean fluorescence intensity which
is the way
the luminex instrumentation
reads out the light units so
all positive patients were positive for
antibody
despite protein all the negatives that
we tested
were negative um
this is a slide that shows you levels
of igg specific
anti-spike antibodies and this was a
surprise to us
because there were many of the
cova 19 patients
that are shown and the left two-thirds
of this graph
that had very good titles of or levels
of igg
but there were several that had very low
levels or
no levels of igg
and um this was quite surprising we
expected that they would all have igg
although i have to stress that
most of these specimens come from
individuals who are donors to the
program at mount sinai to provide
convalescent plasma for uses treatment
um and they are the titus of their
antibodies
are tested and then if they have good
antibody levels they are selected
for uh plasma donors for convalescent
serum
we have no information about how
soon after infection or how soon after
the
end of symptoms these patients
or these subjects are coming in for
testing so
many of these may be relatively early
after infection
and don't seem to have igg antibodies
in contrast and and these slides that
i'm showing you are all the same
patients
in contrast if you look at the iga
from these same individuals all of them
um with the exception of one
individual have iga antibodies
again the baseline is this dotted line
you can just barely see it above the
baseline over on the right
when you're looking at the normal donors
so um
all but one of these individuals have
iga
antibodies and in the next slide
are the igm antibody levels in these
individuals
and in fact every single one of the
individuals who we tested had igm
antibodies
again the levels vary but
all of them had igm so if you
look at the percentage of responders
in meaning individuals who are covered
infected and have antibodies to spike
if you're measuring total ig total
immunoglobulins which includes
igg iga and igm 100 of them have
antibodies
which you would expect but a minority of
them
have igg antibodies 61
92 had iga and 100
had igm so
the 33 specimens that were tested in
this particular series of experiments
um from 31 patients
the patients that we looked at were
actively ill or
the majority of them are convalescent
and the iga and the igm response rates
were higher than the igg response rates
which
was not expected now
um different
you cannot you cannot
compare the levels of antibodies
isotypes um
using different anti igg
iga and igm for example
if you use an anti-igm
secondary antibody you can look at all
of the patients
as we did here and we can say that the
patient with the highest spike
had relative to other patients was
the most robust responder in terms of
igm
but um the level
um that you read maybe
probably is quantitatively different
than you would get with an antibody
against say igg-1 and
i can show you this on the basis of the
y-axis so the y-axis
here read out in main fluorescence
intensity goes up to 300
000 whereas when you're using an
anti-iga
antibody the axis really only goes up
um to about 40 000 and if you're
looking um with anti-igg
you only go up to about 175 thousand
so you can compare between patients with
the same isotype
but you cannot compare levels
within a patient from one isotype to the
next
so in order to understand
better how to analyze the data
what we did was take each one of these
graphs
and drew drew it into quartiles so for
the igm
graph for instance we counted up the
number of
specimens that had the twin cutoff
and 50 000 mfi and we said that that was
the number
of uh specimens that were in the first
quartile
and then the second quartile was between
50
000 and 100 thousand and we counted the
number of
specimens that fell between fifty and a
hundred thousand
and then the third quartile was between
100
and 150 uh mfis
and then the fourth quartile was
anything over the 150
000 uh mfi and so we could do
we could look at patients and say okay
um
is this patient let's say
the first bar is in the first quartile
for igm but um
is perhaps in a higher quartile in
the second quartile for iga
at and is um
let's see and is in say the
second order just barely into the third
quartile for total ig
and using quartiles we can compare
quantitatively the amount of
the different isotypes in different
patients
so what i'm showing you here and on the
next slide
is the analysis in terms of the quartile
so for instance if you look at
patient p number four
this patient specimen is in the third
quartile that's the next the highest
quartile for ig
total ig that's ganm
but this specimen didn't have any igg in
it
it was in a low quartile for iga
but it was in a very high quartile for
igm
so it means that at this point in time
patient number four had mainly an igm
response
if you look down on the bottom row at
patient number seven tf number seven
you can see that the majority of the
response
in this patient is iga and there's very
little igm
and there's a medium amount of igg
now if you look overall at this graph
with this
table what you see is what i showed you
before that
if you look at it's very clear that the
positives
the strongest positives are in the iga
and igm
classes whereas um
many fewer of the individuals have
strong igg
responses the patients at the top here
1a 1b 1c 2a and 2b
we talked about before were acutely ill
severely ill and they are the ones that
have the highest antibody titers
and levels um and that is
um already established in the literature
for the rest of the specimens that i
showed you in the
graphs above um you see again
if you look at tf number nine in the
second row
you can see that the major response is
iga
if you look at tf number 12
i'm sorry number 11 the major response
is igm etc
another way of seeing this the fact that
different patients have different um
relative levels um and left different
relative
patterns of isotypes you can look
at um these two graphs with the which of
the graphs i showed you before for iga
and igm and i've drawn
these two-headed arrows connecting two
of the patients
showing you that the first arrow that
this particular patient
had a great deal of igm
but very little iga
and um i'm sorry had very little iga
igm but a great deal of iga
and the second arrow shows just the
opposite
patient that has a high amount of igm
and very little iga so different
patients have different
patterns of responses
in different isotype categories and
one of the things that is important to
figure out
is why what accounts for these
differences
in responses
what is the utility of isotyping on
these antibodies
the first is to determine if the
presence of different isotypes affects
the therapeutic potential of transfused
convalescent plasma
so right now the convalescent plasma
that's being transfused into
severely ill patients is
chosen on the basis of tighter alone
but it might be better we don't know but
it might be better it might be more
effective
if you chose
units of plasma that had high titers of
igm
for example and we are looking into that
looking at um and asking questions like
this
in conjunction with the transfusion team
at mount sinai
um the second question that
may be answered by these isotoping
studies
is to determine if antibody levels and
isotypes change over time
in convalescent plasma and if this
affects which plasma donors should be
chosen
so you would expect probably
that the isotype patterns will change
over time
and that could imply that some
plasma donors who seem to be
good plasma donors early
after they have recovered from infection
um
even if the tigers stay up the isotype
pattern may have changed
later during recovery
and it might be important to determine
if the isotypes in this serum of plasma
from these individuals
say six months after recovery
is different than the uh
plasma that was derived for transfusion
from these patients say one month after
recovery
and finally it's it's very important to
understand
um the nature of the antiviral antibody
response
the relative protective activities of
the different antibody iso
isotypes and the immunopathogenesis that
might be
induced by antibodies
that have have been produced in response
to the virus
finally i want to talk about the
reproducibility of the assay
i'm showing you in this slide
the correlations between two
anti-spike antibody experiments
and you can see the the very good
correlations the
um our values are
above 0.9 the p-values are less than
0.0001
for each of the
isotypes that we were looking at so it's
a very reproducible assay to assay
um and you would expect that there would
be a correlation
in the presence and levels
of antibodies to spike and to
rbd and that also is true
as you can see here all of the p-values
are less than point zero zero zero one
finally let me um sum up um what
i have told you um in today's webinar
um we have developed a luminex-based
assay
for copen19 antibodies which is both
qualitative or binary and it is
quantitative
the advantages of the luminex assay
versus the elisa assay is that it uses
20 fold less antigen per test
it can be run at least two and a half
fold faster than the
eliza itself is run the turnaround time
is less than a day versus two days for
the elisa
you can perform the rbd screen
and the spike titration simultaneously
whereas with eliza it has to be done
sequentially
and the level of sensitivity is five to
ten
fold better for luminex than for elisa
and this results in fewer false
negatives
the isotypes of covin-19 antibody and
serum and plasma can be analyzed
and quantitated the relative patterns of
iggs
iga and igm differ from patient's
patient
and the iga and igm response rates were
higher than the igg response rates
at least during the period of time
from which the specimens were collected
at this relatively early stage of the
pandemic
and the sensitivity and specificity of
the assay
using rbd and spike proteins is quite
high
in conclusion i would like to
acknowledge
the fantastic people who i've worked
with
um wonderful scientists and
uh wonderful collaborators in particular
uh stenya
vice and jeremy klingler who are
post-doctoral fellows in in the lab and
dr katarina hugh
who is a principal investigator who i've
worked closely with for
many many years so i
thank them especially and all of the
people who are listed here
i show my contact information down below
in case you would like any further
information about the
assay that we have developed and thank
you
very much um susie i'm ready to take
any questions that may come up
and thank you dr zola pazner for that
informative presentation
and we will now start that q a portion
of our webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we have quite a few questions already
coming in
dr zola pausner our first
question from our audience number is
what dilution
of the serum is used in the assay
so for the screen we have been using the
one to two hundred dilution
for the titrations we usually go from
one
to fifty out to
um about one to ten thousand
but it's sufficient to screen at one to
two hundred
thank you for that and do you know
if the pre-pandemic positive signals
you reported were a result of the
cross-reactivity
with another coronavirus infection or
covid19
in other words was there a respiratory
pathogen
panel performed no
we did not do a respiratory
disease panel but dr florian kramer did
i believe that is published in
his paper which was
in nature medicine about a month ago
and he did not find any cross-reactivity
between the copa and other coronaviruses
of the 50 specimens that we looked at
only one of them
had a positive a positive signal they
all should have been negative one of
them was positive
against spike and negative
against rbd we don't have any clinical
information on
that particular patient
thank you for that and do you see the
difference
in using serum versus plasma
in the a b test and it's a two-part
question actually
is there an impact of ab um
uh let's see type titers
in using the lip hammock and
hemolyzed samples i apologize if i
mispronounced that
okay so um we don't see any difference
in
[Music]
any difference in looking at serum or
plasma
i say that because
our values are very similar for the
paddle
panels of serum and plasma that we're
using
although we have not tested in parallel
serum and plasma from the same donor
at the same time point but we're not
seeing
any significant differences between
serum
and plasma results and so
we are concluding that you can use
either one
in your assay um
i am not sure about the
question of whether hemolysis
impacts the results my impression is
that it doesn't
because some of the assays
that we have done and i didn't show you
those
data in my presentation but we we have
been working with what some specimens
that are hemolyzed and we're still
getting good reads with them
so again i don't have a specimen that
comes from
the same donor the same bleed that is
hemolyzed and
is not but my impression is
that um if the antibodies are there
um the hemolysis does not seem to
um create an artifact
thank you for that i want to thank our
audience for these great questions
that are coming in we have time for a
couple of more
um this next audience member says very
nice presentation thank you so much
tetris flex and um
array sars cove to
human igg assay for luminix platform
and we validated our assay and submitted
eua
application they want to know if he'd be
possibly interested in comparing the
essay with yours
absolutely there you go
right um
my contact my contact information was at
the bottom of the last slide i don't
know if you can still see it or not
but you can look me up on the
mount side i website
and you'll find it wonderful always
great how
people can get the collaborative
opportunities from these presentations
for the coupling of the s antigen to be
did you find that you needed to use the
avidin beads
or did you use the standard mag pix
microspheres
um i'm not familiar with
the alternative um
i i know that we have used
the the the beads come from from luminex
and i don't remember the exact
um model number
um but i can provide that information to
you
offline if you send me an email
thank you so much we have time for one
more question
can you please comment on the stability
of the luminix
acids when you freeze versus storage at
four degrees
um you know it really depends on
the antigen that you're using so
um recombinant antigens can be fussy
and can go bad um we
of course we've only had a couple of
months to be dealing with the
spike protein and rbd and we have not
had
any difficulty with them we have
we we usually store our coated beads
especially if we make large amounts of
them
at -80 and then
if there's any left over we will keep
them at four degrees
and use them for the rest of that week
but never longer than that
thank you for that and just um i
want to say dr zola pognan thank you for
this presentation did you want to
provide any closing remarks for our
audience before we leave today
i just think that it's important
to point out that with the
scale up for mass screening that is
really going to be required
nationally and internationally that this
platform provides the ability to scale
up
in a much more efficient way
than using the eliza format so
this is a an assay
design that would best be
suited for reference labs where you're
doing
thousands of tests a day and and
that is what it was designed for
absolutely and thank you again for this
incredible presentation and for your
important research and before we go
i want to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
i'd also like to thank our sponsors
luminix for sponsoring today's
webinar questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through the end of the year 2020.
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event until next time
have a great day and be safe bye-bye
thank you